Fending is this visceral animal kingdom truth
that applies to us humans.
We're mammals.
We have jackets and cell phones, right,
we wear fancy watches and sneakers and we're mammals.
And like any mammal parent,
we have to know for our own biological determination,
like we have to know our genes get passed on.
How do our genes get passed on?
If our kids can fend for themselves out in the world
without us, like any mammal.
Parent, we need to know that.
(upbeat music)
I don't know about you, but despite having great parents,
despite the privilege of having a world-class education,
nobody actually ever taught me how to be an adult.
And as a result, I made a ton of avoidable mistakes.
I suffered more than I needed to.
I fumbled around until eventually
I figured a few things out.
And I think my personal experience, unfortunately,
is all too common.
Well today's guest, Julie Lythcott-Haims would agree.
So she decided to do something about it.
Julie is the former Dean of Freshmen
and Undergraduate Advising at Stanford University,
where she also earned her BA and we were classmates.
I first met Julie when we were both 18.
She also earned a law degree from Harvard
and a master's in fine arts and writing
from California College of the Arts.
Today she's an author and she's an authority
on what we now call in Millennial parlance, adulting.
Her books include the New York Times bestseller,
"How to Raise an Adult."
She also wrote "Real American,"
which is a beautiful memoir centered on coming to terms
with her racial identity.
And her latest, and the focus of today's conversation
is called "Your Turn: How to Be an Adult,"
which is a really powerful, beautiful book.
For those just emerging into the grown-up world,
I think it's a must-read handbook for those people.
For parents, it's a must-gift for the young adults,
and it's a book I very much wish existed when I was young.
This one is packed with practical insights
for both parents and young people alike.
So please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy my conversation with Julie Lythcott-Haims.
(whooshing sound)
So nice to see you.
It's really good to see you
and to be here and to have flown here.
It's a big experience, I'm glad to be here.
We talked about doing this when the book came out
and I was just so reluctant to do this on Zoom
in a remote context.
So we waited, it took a minute, but here we.
Are, I'm delighted.
Yeah, and it's wild because we go way back.
Like I met you first week of freshman year at Stanford,
we were both 18, 17, something like that.
I briefly dated your freshman roommate at Brander,
where I spent a ton of time in that dorm.
And what's so, the more I reflect on your story and my own,
what's interesting is that we're very different people.
We have divergent backgrounds and experiences, of course,
but here's the thing, I mean, irrespective
of meeting at 18 and we weren't like friends in college,
but I knew you and I've sort of followed you over the years.
We're both Gen Xers who grew up
with very achievement-oriented parents.
And that made us sort of go getters
among a generation of the, kind of forgotten latchkey kids.
That is the hallmark of what it means to be Gen X.
We're both hypercompetitive, people pleasers.
What?
Right?
Yes.
And, and those tendencies both led us
into corporate law careers,
the misery that that produces.
You got out earlier than I did,
but that kind of overlap in our Venn diagram,
is interesting.
I agree.
It's been really cool to kind of watch you evolve
over the years and step into this position of authority
on the subject matter that we're gonna talk about today.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks for noticing all that.
You know, you were this,
you were part of that cadre of athletes
who came by and there was this aura surrounding y'all
because the program you were part of was elite
and we all knew it and respected it.
You know, Stanford had that unique blend of irreverence
and high achievement of athletics and academics.
And here you were part of that group and so I did not,
we weren't friends, as you said,
but I definitely knew of you and knew that people
respected and admired you.
And I've loved watching your journey.
I've loved watching the ways in which you have dared
to be vulnerable with the world,
with strangers, about your path.
And I love how you're serving people.
I appreciate that, that means a lot.
It's been a journey for both us.
For sure.
And I think what, one of the many things
that I loved so much about Stanford,
was this sense of possibility.
Like I grew up on the East Coast,
and you know, was reared in a kind of checklist household,
which is something you talk a lot about
where it's like you do these certain things
and you're on a certain track.
And I was able to be successful within that construct,
but it wasn't until I got to Stanford.
And I wouldn't say Stanford had the most diverse
student body, but there was a diversity of experiences.
And I think layered on top of that,
this sense of possibility,
like an environment that was conducive
to trying to bring the best out of people
in whatever it was that they were interested in,
and it was the one place where, you know,
I visited a lot of colleges and they would say,
well, you can either excel as an athlete
or you can excel academically.
You're not gonna really be able to do both.
You're gonna have to choose.
And Stanford was like, no, you can do both.
Like let us help you figure out how to make that happen.
And I just, that, maybe it's a California sensibility,
I don't know, but I just really fell in love with that.
And I loved being a student there, even though, you know,
it, you know, I can't say I made the most
of that experience.
Well, we all have our regrets about college,
is probably not a person listening
if they went to college who doesn't.
You know, when I think about that special blend at Stanford,
Rich, I think there's a profound respect
for the individual there.
And yeah, it is a place that contends
with stereotypes and whatnot,
but the dominant stereotype nationally,
that it is not possible to excel as a scholar
and as an athlete, that stereotype is shattered at Stanford.
And, I think that's part of the magnificence of the place.
You spent many years as Dean of Freshmen there.
And in that capacity, I can only imagine the experiences
that you had, not so much dealing with the kids,
but having to deal with the parents,
which has obviously, you know, of course,
informed the books that you've written
and given you this perspective on parenting.
Yeah, absolutely.
A real surprise, frankly, I got there actually in '98,
I left law in '98,
became the Associate Dean for Student Affairs
at the law school for two years.
Spent a couple years in the president's office
and then said, hey, I think we would be a better place
as a world-class research university.
If we had a tiny office dedicated
to the needs of our newest,
to the needs of those at the very bottom of the totem pole.
And they said, yeah, go give it a try, you know,
give you a dilapidated office, someone has vacated.
I pitched, you know, myself to apple computer,
for some computers and made a go of it.
And, you know, our ethos, our philosophy was,
I wanna be sure, we wanna be sure
everybody is not just admitted,
but knows they've been let in.
And it really speaks to the potential exclusion
of myriad folks who for whatever reason,
don't feel entitled to be in the center of the page.
And so to try to lead with a philosophy of you belong here,
you matter to us, you're not a nameless, faceless number,
your journey is of relevance to us.
Your needs matter.
We are here to try to be alongside you
as you begin to figure yourself out.
That was kind of the big picture,
purpose of what we're doing.
And yeah, in those years of this sort of in 2002,
when I began in that role,
we had begun to see on the campus,
maybe four to six years earlier,
parents doing unusual things.
parents, you know, needing to talk to a faculty member
about a grade or parents wanting to register their quote,
air quote, child for class.
And in the early years of it, Rich, we giggled.
I'd get a call or an email,
and you know, very politely explained to the parent,
I'm sorry, I can't give you your son or daughter's password.
We can't give them to third parties.
Oh, I'm not a third party, I'm his mom.
Well, no, actually you are, you know.
Or it's too hard or he's so busy or she's so busy.
And you know, I'd be polite and respectful
and articulate the rules
and then I'd hang up or hit send on the email
and go down the hall and find a colleague
and relay the story.
Like you're not gonna believe this, parents so crazy.
And then they really increased in number.
So it became less, this sort of one-off weird parent
you joked about, this would have been the early 2000s.
And as the numbers grew,
it really became a population of people
We had to take seriously and contend with.
It was clear that childhood had changed.
So parents were arriving differently on campus.
They were arriving and staying,
they weren't just dropping you off or helping you move in.
They felt they had a role to play
in the day-to-day management of life,
in the life of their child.
And I found myself thinking, you know,
this child could be in the Marines,
but here they are, you know,
not putting their lives in danger.
They're at a well-resourced university,
which you're paying a tremendous amount
for them to attend, quite likely.
What are you so afraid of, parent?
Why is it that you think you need to be the one
to have the run of the mill conversation
with a faculty member?
To get involved if there's a roommate dispute,
to attend an overseas studies orientation,
'cause you don't think your child can go abroad
unless you've had the orientation
so that we know how we can be successful abroad.
We listened to the pronouns changing.
It was we're going abroad.
We've gotten into this seminar.
So those were some the changes I noticed,
and my job was to root for young people to thrive.
And I could see that those who were over-managed
were lacking in agency,
And I found myself asking, hey kid,
have you ever made a choice?
Have they let you make a choice?
Or you just incredibly good at doing what you're told?
And it saddened me.
Yeah, produces a certain handicap where the child,
not only lacks self-efficacy,
but that produces lower self-esteem
and a lower sense of their own inherent capabilities.
And certainly, you know, Stanford is your experience,
but this is not, you know, endemic simply to Stanford.
This is a nationwide, if not a global thing
that is so fascinating.
And I feel like has only continued to metastasize.
So the catch all kind of umbrella phrase for this
is helicopter parenting, of course,
or, you know, the tiger mom phenomenon.
What is your sense of how this started
and how we got to this situation?
Very interestingly,
there were a set of changes happening
in this country in the mid '80s
that conspired to in the aggregate change all of childhood.
So in no particular order, Rich, five things.
Stranger danger was born with a made for TV movie, Adam,
about the abduction and murder of Adam Walsh in 1983.
And everybody watched it, there was no internet.
All of your entertainment came through the big screen
or the small screen or your headphones.
Everybody tuned in for that show
And it scared the bejesus out of everybody.
So stranger danger was born '83.
And then that guy's dad became the host
of what was the show that he did-
"America's Most Wanted."
Exactly.
Yeah, John Walsh, exactly.
And missing kids began appearing on,
photos began appearing on milk cartons.
And yes, occasionally children were abducted by strangers.
And it is of course, as we know, as parents,
the most horrific thing we can imagine,
and yet children are more likely to die
at the hands of a family member
than they are at the hands of a stranger.
They're more likely to die as a passenger in a car,
yet we drive them in cars constantly
to get them to and from their activities.
So we reshaped childhood
around the very, very, very infinitesimal likelihood
of a stranger harming our children.
And we can really trace that back to that movie.
"Adam," 1983, the play date was born in 1984.
Kids used to play with each other.
We found each other, right, Rich?
It was like, where are the bikes?
That's where my friends are.
That was a Gen X childhood.
That changed.
Parents started arranging play with other parents,
deciding with whom and when,
but also watching over it hovering, micromanaging.
Are they playing with the right things?
Are they bored, let me help them.
The self-esteem movement, give them ribbons and trophies,
certificates and awards just for playing soccer
or just for swimming, rather for being any good at it.
The notion that we need to always praise, great job, Billy,
you slid down the slide, great job.
He didn't hit jack, you know.
A nation at risk was published saying American teenagers
needed to be, you know, more high achieving
vis-a-vis their international counterparts.
We needed more testing, more teaching to the test.
All of these things meant that childhood
was now watched and managed by parents.
We also got safer in cars with seatbelt laws
and car seat laws and bike helmet laws, and bicycles.
We got safer in our transportation,
it led to this mindset of, you can put a helmet on them,
always you can bubble-wrap every aspect
of their environment, prepare the road for the kid,
instead of prepare the kid for the road.
All of those things happened
in the span of three to five years.
The first kids to come to college on mask with parents
who couldn't let go in the late '90s,
were the first have been subjected to play dates in 1984.
And it, and why does it persist?
'Cause it works, Rich.
When you stand next to the rock wall
and prevent your kid from falling
onto the plastic woodchips, they go unharmed.
So you've saved them in that moment.
But over the longterm, your kid hasn't developed
that kinesthetic sense of how their body works
or of how to do something different or better next time.
So short-term win, long-term loss.
Right, and on top of that,
it's all set up within the construct of performance, right.
How do I set my kid up to get into the best college?
Like that is the ultimate end game.
And so when you're looking at short-term gains,
it's all oriented around academic performance,
making sure that they have the appropriate extracurriculars
and the only way to ensure
that is this level of over-involvement.
But, of course, even in the successful cases
where a kid ends up at Stanford,
that kid ends up knocking on your door,
you know, having all kinds of, you know, mental issues
or self-esteem issues or, you know, body dysmorphia,
I'm sure it shows up in a million different ways
where they're handicapped and unable to really figure out
how to live and exist and thrive on their own.
That's exactly right.
So we've done the thinking for them, the planning for them,
the troubleshooting, the fixing,
the managing, the handling all in further,
and some of these outcomes,
we think lead to a successful life.
And it's almost like we take our helicopter rotors
and we lift them in the helicopter
and arrive them at the future we have in mind.
And then we can say, look, you've arrived.
You're here.
And then the kid is bewildered at the place of arrival,
because they haven't done the heavy-lifting.
They've certainly worked hard.
It's not to say that kids aren't hardworking
in this context, but they've been so over-managed
and over helped, they really are unfamiliar
with their own selves.
And in my first book, how to reason at all,
I call it "Existential Impotence: Unfamiliar With the Self."
My sense is that there's a pendulum that swings
and that's that pendulum swings generation to generation
where parents end up parenting and opposition
to the way that they were parented
to ensure that their kid gets
what they feel like they didn't get, right.
So if you have the Gen Xers,
who were the latchkey kids
who were completely unattended to,
they're gonna be the ones who are more likely
to show up and over-parents.
Is that how you feel like it works
or have we arrived in a situation now
where the pendulum has kind of locked in this place
where parents are fixated in an unhealthy way
on how their kids are doing and performing.
I certainly agree with you that many of us
want to parent either the opposite of how we were raised,
or we appreciate how we were raised,
and we wanna do it the exact same way.
We don't seem to have room for nuance.
I wanna point out that it was the Baby Boomers
that started the helicopter parenting phenomenon.
We Gen Xers inherited it because you're in a community
and you see how other parents are doing their kids' homework
in the fourth grade, in the seventh grade.
Well, how are you not gonna do your kid's homework?
'Cause you need your kid to keep up, right?
So we arrived as parents in an environment
where helicopter parenting was already in many communities.
The norm, and I find it ironic that Baby Boomers
who questioned authority,
I mean, that was their bumper sticker.
When they were young, they were now questioning authority
on behalf of their own kids.
They had forgotten that they created and matured
their own voice by using it.
And instead they sort of treated their own kids
like little pets and projects
that they would continually question authority
on their behalf.
With Gen X, you know, many of us can appreciate
the freedoms of that latchkey childhood.
Yes, there were examples that were neglectful
and harmful and none of us want to replicate that.
But you see in the Gen X memes on social media,
the kind of lauding, the pride of like, you know,
look what I was able to do.
Look what my childhood entailed.
There's pride in that.
And I hope that Gen Xers listening will ask themselves,
why am I not offering that same degree of freedom
to my own child?
Why do I want less for them?
The justification that that the parent will make
is that this is all for the best,
all in the best interest of the child.
Like that's all that I care about.
I just wanna set my kid up for success,
but beneath that, what you find is a really unhealthy
level of inmeshment.
This like projection onto their child,
that their performance is a reflection of how well
the parent parented the kid, right.
You know, I grew up in Washington, DC,
that's a community, you know,
in upwardly mobile neighborhoods
where everybody puts the bumper sticker on the car
of the school that the kid goes to.
And it's such an unhealthy thing where the parent
is so wrapped up in how well the kid does,
because they wanna be able to go to the cocktail party
and say this, that or the other that reflects well on them.
Right, so I talk about, we treat our kids
like they're our bonsai trees.
You know, the bonsai is such an exquisite creation
of the gardener.
The gardener decides the direction
in which that tree will grow,
which branches will be clipped
and which will flourish and the shape of it.
And it's a lovely creation.
But at the end of the day, it is a possession
of the gardener.
It's something to be ooed and odd over,
and people can come to a gardener and say,
look what you've done, aren't you amazing?
And you know, I'm super clear
and let me say, as a caveat,
I have over-parented my own two.
They are 20 and 22.
I am in this both as quote, unquote expert
and as subject, okay.
We now treat our kids like they're our bonsai trees
that, you know, we need them to be glorious
so that we can feel better about ourselves,
and it's harmful.
And it speaks to an unwellness in our psyche, in our spirit.
How many of us are devoting countless hours
to chauffeuring, concierging, helping with the homework,
over-helping outright doing the homework,
planning and fixing and managing our kids' lives.
And we have a primary partner over there in the wings.
And our relationship with that person
is dwindling and diminishing and suffering
'cause we're not watering that plant.
We're not giving that relationship attention,
the very relationship that might've created these children,
you know, languishes because we are investing everything
in the project that is making these children excellent
so that we can feel that we have, you know,
the right sort of accolades to boast about
at a cocktail party.
Yeah, I think it was in your TED talk
where you said they're not bonsai trees,
They're wildflowers.
Yeah.
And you know, that image instantly comes to mind for me of,
you know, being out on a trail
somewhere in our beautiful California
and taking in the majesty of a wild landscape,
you know, that's who we, humans are.
Yes, there are some rules and regulations
we all need to abide by
in order to play nicely with one another.
But there's so much room for variants, for difference.
We have, you know, some core things in common
and yet each of one of us is this unique, precious thing.
You know, I like the poet, Mary Oliver,
is very much in my heart as I talk to young people,
you know, they'll say,
how do I tell my parents I don't wanna be a,
whatever the parents have decided is the right path,
the sort of tiger type.
How do I, you know, and I'm trying to incentivize
a young person to claim their own agency.
And one of the phrases I use is from Mary Oliver,
who said in one of her poems,
what is it, tell me, she said,
"Tell me, what is it you plan to do
"with this one wild, precious life."
It is wild.
It should be.
It is precious.
And unlike the bonsai tree that requires
that pruning and that level of deep involvement,
the wildflower is fine on its own.
Maybe you gotta water it a little bit once in a while,
but you walk away from it-
That's right.
And let it do its thing.
Let it become what it is.
And that's terrifying for a lot of parents.
And as a parent of four, you know,
I brought up against that as well.
I appreciate how you bring your own experiences
into your writing.
And you're very frank about where you've done it right,
and where you still find yourself, you know,
tripping up and repeating patterns that you learned
from your parents and how unconscious those impulses can be.
Absolutely, you know, I'm a memoirist.
I try to write non-fiction because I believe in the beauty
that can come when we can dare to be vulnerable
about our lived experience.
I know that a deep, profound, meaningful connection
with other humans is available when we can open up
or when we can pull the facade or mask away
and say, you know what, I did this.
And I try to tell the truth to the extent I can bear it.
There are still plenty of truths
I can't yet bear to tell, but I'm only 53.
We'll see if I get more years,
who knows, I may write more.
It gives people permission to express,
or at least contend with their own vulnerabilities.
Like if you're creating a space in which,
look, I can say this,
maybe you can bring to the surface
something that you've been repressing or hiding.
And I think we need more of that now.
And you know, if there is a fear with Gen Z
and the younger generation, the digital natives,
it's that they're so accustomed to communicating
in a digital space and yet completely handicapped
when it comes to how to actually interact
with another individual in three-dimensional space
in real time.
Absolutely, one-on-one, in-person.
You know, in my new book which is aimed at helping
young adults thrive or really helping anyone
live their best life as an adult,
I talk about humans being everything
about human relationships at the end of the day,
being the predictor or one of the greatest predictors
of our longevity.
I know you have done plenty of work on your own
and you know plenty of people who have all kinds of wisdom
about how to live and thrive.
And certainly we know from the Harvard Grant Project,
Harvard Grant study, that's lasted for decades,
that it's not your cholesterol level at 50
that determines whether you live a long life.
It's the quality of your relationships at 50.
And so I'm trying to help young people
who haven't had a childhood
where they just had to sit around with their friends
and figure out what they wanted to do.
And instead of had access to friends via technology,
I'm trying to help them learn how to go deep with a person.
What are the questions you ask
when you're really seeking to know.
How do you show up with your body and your mind
and your energy, if you're really seeking
to demonstrate care and concern and interest.
These are the things, I think if I was a parent today
of young ones, I would be really focused
on helping them develop that emotional intelligence,
those soft skills around interacting
with your fellow humans.
Yeah, it's so crucial, and yet our educational system
is bereft of any of that type of education.
And I think it requires
a certain level of emotional maturity
on behalf of parents to recognize
the importance of that and to emphasize it.
You know, I just reflect back on, you know,
when I was in my early 20s, I didn't have the facility
to have that type of conversation.
And I often lament the fact that I was at this
unbelievable institution and didn't make
appropriate use of it to engage with my inner voice.
Never once that I asked myself,
what is it that I wanna be?
I was on this track, this is what I was gonna do.
This was what I was, you know, sort of set up to do.
And didn't have any emotional intelligence
to even ask myself what it is that, you know,
makes me uniquely me,
what gets all these questions that you ask in the book,
like what gets you excited?
What gets you out of bed in the morning?
Like, what are the activities
that you naturally gravitate towards?
I was just on this habit trail.
And I do remember, I mean, times are very different now.
I do remember, and I'm interested
in whether you have this experience.
I remember going to, and I've told this story before,
going to the Career Center at Stanford,
'cause I was like, I dunno what I wanna do.
And I remember there was a coffee table
with some brochures on it
and it was like Boston Consulting Group,
Anderson Consulting, you know, Merrill Lynch.
And that was kind of it.
None of that, I was like, I don't even know what that is.
Like what is consulting?
Everybody seems to be interviewing
with these consulting companies.
Like what exactly am I supposed to consult on?
I don't know anything.
And so law school just sort of happened
because I didn't know quite what to do.
And that was the socially approved route.
Yeah.
Oh, rich, what was your major?
Home bio.
I started out as home bio and then I thought
I would wanna to be a doctor.
And I've often thought, you know, I kind of,
I started partying too much and lost interest in that
and pivoted to American studies, which I enjoyed.
I was an American studies major.
I'm sure we were in the same classes.
I can't believe this.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know, yeah.
So first of all, I'm feeling a lot of compassion
for your 18 to 22-year-old self who didn't know,
who didn't ask the right questions, so to speak,
who wishes, maybe he could go back and do those
or some of those opportunities over again.
I think it's a pretty universal lament though.
You know, at 18 to 22, as we now know your prefrontal cortex
is just starting to get itself locked in.
And the expectation that you should know at that time,
I think is a really ridiculous burden
that we place on young people.
It is ridiculous.
And it's gotten worse because nowadays
in any independent high school
and any well-healed public high school in America today,
a child is asked at ninth grade, what is your passion?
Find your passion, find your passion, kid, quick.
You know, like it's hiding on a bookshelf
and if they just work hard enough, they can find it.
Why?
Because a college admissions dean wants to know about it
in their senior year.
In January of their senior year or preferably November,
'cause we want you to apply early, right.
Find your passion in pursuit of pleasing somebody else
who is going to admit or deny a new opportunity to you.
It's become this utilitarian perfunctory thing.
I mean, I believe in passion and path and purpose
and the rudder that steers you
no matter which way the wind is going,
that I know my why.
That's what I think of as passionate.
I'm just sort of really against the notion
that every 18-year-old must have one
outside of the fellow 18-year-old they're attracted to,
I mean, that's a natural passion
for someone at 18 to have.
To know your life's pursuit at 18, I think is rare.
Yeah, I mean, defacto, when you're that age,
you've only been exposed to a limited number of experiences.
So how could you possibly know that?
I think a work that has been instrumental
in helping me rethink that,
and I think every young person should read
is David Epstein's "Range"
because we have this idea that a young person
who toggles between many different things
and can't quite commit and, you know,
appears on the surface to sort of be lazy and disengaged.
And somebody we would call a dilettante
is actually just experimenting and exposing themselves
to a number of experiences as part of that necessary process
of either elimination or selection, right.
So that book, I don't know if you've read it.
Haven't.
But it basically puts to the test
the idea that high performers in all areas of life,
from academia to sports, science, et cetera, art,
were people who at a very young age splashed onto it
and did the 10,000 hours thing,
distinguished themselves,
when in truth the reality is that these people
are people who did lots of different things
as a young person and have many, many experiences
that then all inform the thing that they finally key in on
and become an expert in.
You know, I think I've done my 10,000 hours
across three different careers,
and more than 10,000 hours.
It took me some time to tell myself
the truth that I'm a people-person go damn it,
and I'm gonna be a people person
and I'm here to be a people person.
I think when I was young,
I thought the fact that I had people skills,
I knew I had people skills when I was little
people would come to me and ask me questions
revealing vulnerability.
They seem to value my perspective,
they seem to feel safe with me.
That has been true all my life
as far back as I can remember.
But I think, Rich, I thought that being a people person
was somehow attached to my gender.
I'm female, female-presenting,
maybe it's a, you know, sort of female, girly thing.
I didn't value it as a skill.
We weren't speaking about soft skills or EQ
when you and I were in college.
I think I just discarded it.
I was hell bent on being a left brain, analytical lawyer
who was gonna have, you know, a profession
that would allow me to make change in the world
and help people.
I knew I wanted to help people,
but I wanted to do it in a way that society told me
was the right way.
Tap into your intellect, tap into your left brain.
Whereas the right brain side of me
and the very soft EQ side of me was really underserved,
massively underserved when I chose corporate law,
which of course was not a way to help people.
It was a way to help me feel
that I was meeting society's expectations.
That was my people-pleasing side,
as you alluded to at the start.
And so finally in my misery, I came around to,
you know what, I'm a people person.
I need to do work, helping people.
I need to figure that out, Julie,
get back on the path that you know is your right path.
And I keep iterating around to, okay,
so what is the best way for me to try to help people now,
now that I know what I know.
I've been observing people for 53 years
and in my work I'm continually trying
to take whatever I've learned across those many hours
of being immersed with humans,
to try to turn that into something I can offer people back
by way of assistance.
Right, and perhaps all those different avenues
that you pursued, all inform the,
you know, the depth of the resonance
that you can now share, right?
It's not like, oh, I regret doing that.
On some level, I'm sure those experiences contribute
to the value that you can now share.
100%.
Yeah, for example I know doesn't matter
how much money they pay you,
if you're miserable in the work,
the money will never be compensation enough.
And we can hear that a million times,
but until you experience it.
That's right.
It's different.
But I'm also rooting for us not to have
the high blood pressure before we leave the work
or not to have our hair falling out
before we decide to pivot.
That's when we tend to give ourselves permission, right.
I am dying here.
We have that objective evidence
that this isn't working for me.
And that allows us to say to our dads and moms and friends
and society like, okay, I couldn't take this.
And I'm rooting for us all to find that truer north
before the body starts to scream at us,
stop, you're hurting me.
What was the Rubicon for you with corporate law
and getting out?
It was the high blood pressure.
I mean, nine months in, I had a knot in my stomach
at 2:00 PM on a Sunday,
knowing I had to go back.
I loved the people, you know, the feeling.
If you weren't at the office already-
Yeah, I was gonna say it, right, exactly, exactly.
Every lawyer would make that caveat.
Let me be clear.
I was at a great firm as far as firms go,
great place, good people.
You were at Cooley, right?
I was at Cooley in Palo Alto.
Where were you?
I was at Littler Mendelson in San Francisco for a while.
And then I moved down here
to work in a entertainment litigation firms.
Okay, I was at Cooley, then I was in the house at Intel,
pam, pam, pam, pam, as a trademark lawyer,
which is why I have to do that.
So you took (indistinct) you had some self-awareness
to know, like maybe the law firm thing isn't good enough,
but that's the typical sort of sidestep,
like, oh, in-house-
Go in-house, the hours are better, right?
But here's the thing.
After nine months, I had the knot in the stomach
on the weekend.
I was going into my doctor to frankly,
I think, try to get pregnant.
And she discovered my blood pressure was high.
And she wanted me to wear a cuff five times a day.
And it was low in the morning and it was low at night
and it was high at work.
And so that was data.
And I began to, I did this exercise with myself.
I was, you know, sort of miserable out of my back porch
and Menlo park one night it just,
and mad at myself for being miserable.
'Cause I'd done everything right, air quotes, right.
The right college, the right law school,
the right career, the right life,
good money, mentor, great opportunity,
like they were telling me, hey kid, you're good at this.
And so I couldn't understand my own discomfort
because I'd done everything right, so to speak.
So I was impatient with myself
and I had gone to law school to help people
and now here I was miserable as a lawyer, you know,
wanted to help those in misery now feeling misery myself.
And I gave myself this sort of tongue lashing,
like you are not suffering.
You know, you are unhappy, but figure it out
because you have been given so much by way of opportunity.
You've got to figure out your way back to helping people.
The solution lies in your will,
your application of your will to this problem.
Yeah, so I tried to leave three times.
I knew our alma mater was up the street.
I still had these very fond feelings for it.
As I do to this day, I was driving past Hoover Tower,
you know, between home and work.
And it was beckoning.
Like you can work with people,
you can help people here, Julie.
So I tried to get a job in student affairs
and I tried to get a job in admissions.
And I tried for another job in student affairs.
And every single time I'd make it far in the process
with a great cover letter and great interviewing skills.
And then they'd say you don't have the skills actually
to be a student affairs person
'cause you didn't study this, you studied law.
And finally, I caught a lucky break.
I filled in for somebody on maternity leave.
That tells you where my will was,
and that tells you the risk I was willing to take.
I went to my boss at Intel and said,
I think I don't wanna be this type of lawyer anymore.
I think I want a new career.
I have a chance to test drive it by filling in for somebody,
will you hold my job for 10 weeks, 12 weeks?
And she said, yeah, for your sake, I hope you like it,
for my sake, I hope you don't.
(indistinct)
Well, if she had said, no, I would've quit.
Yeah, but I thought,
'cause I was so determined at that point,
I thought I better at least ask if I can,
if she'll save my job for me, if she'll hold it.
But if she doesn't, I know I'm gonna leave.
It felt like an escape hatch.
And I had to take it
even if it was only a 12-week opportunity.
And the stakes even higher,
because you're the primary breadwinner
in the household, right?
Like your husband works part-time and is a caregiver.
I certainly did once the kids came.
At that time, we didn't have our kids yet,
but that would be our pattern,
our way of being parents, yeah.
Yeah, so, and I take pride in not just being a breadwinner,
but a huge piece of my identity is wrapped up in my work.
My husband is far less so that way.
And so, yeah, I was determined to find work
I was both good at and loved.
I think that's what the knot in my stomach
and the blood pressure taught me.
Doesn't matter if you're good at it if you hate it.
You know, Andre Agassi, famous athlete,
who's, you know, reportedly had that experience
of, you know, best in the world for a time,
but pretty darn miserable at times.
And, you know, I tell parents like,
you don't wanna raise an Andre Agassi.
You wanna raise a Jeremy Lin, you know,
who was improbably great at basketball and loved it
and had his moment of absolute ecstasy in that sport.
(whooshing sound)
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits,
vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com.
Promo code, RRHealth for $10 off
an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
(whooshing sound)
It's interesting what's happening in sports right now,
particularly women's sports with Naomi Osaka,
like basically saying I'm taking a mental health break
and all the kind of, you know,
kerfuffle that happened around that.
And then did you see what just happened with Simone Biles?
Not a physical injury,
just saying it's a mental health thing and I'm opting out.
Like, that is wild.
It's gotta be wild.
I know that you have a degree of appreciation
as an elite athlete that many can't possibly have
for that circumstance.
From my vantage point, they're both black women as am I,
and the pressure we are under when we step out
onto our platform, whatever it is,
the pressure we are under in this America is immense.
We are said to be sort of the exception
when we break stereotype
and we are held to such impossibly high standards,
and when we fall, then the vitriol comes.
And I know without knowing
either of these two remarkable young women,
I know that the hate that they get on social media,
the way in which they're excoriated,
impacts their mental health.
In addition to, I'm sure, the stress and pressure
of being an elite athlete and all that comes with it.
So my goodness, what a remarkable thing it is
that they can say, you know what, I'm out.
I can't, I'm not, I'm choosing not to do this.
I'm choosing to step to the side and do something
that is even more important than winning this tournament
or this medal, whatever it may be.
To do that at the Olympics when,
you know, Simone being set up to be the darling
of the entire games and all the success leading up to that
and all the expectations,
like I can't begin to fathom what her interior experience
must be like and the level of courage it must've taken
to just make that stand
when so many people are invested in that success.
And we treat our elite athletes like their race horses,
and that is we're betting on them and we need them to win.
And we're on the side of this one, not this one.
We see it in the NFL.
We see it in the NBA.
We see someone like Laura Ingraham saying to,
I believe it was LeBron James, shut up and play, right.
And I'm here to say, as an African American woman,
we are not your race horses.
We are not your animals.
We are human beings who have dreams and fears,
and we bleed, and we cry.
And, my God, every one of us, Rich,
just wants to be treated with dignity and kindness.
You know, you know, 'cause I've heard you talk about it.
That's the message of Black Lives Matter.
It's not we matter more.
I'm not trying to be black supremacists.
We're saying can't black life and black lives matter, too.
And I think, you know, this dignity is probably
one of the main adjectives I would use
to describe Simone Biles right now.
I mean, I think she even, if I read it correctly,
one of her quotes was,
you know, I was worried about my performance,
my ability to perform and I didn't wanna jeopardize
the team's chance of meddling.
Here are people saying now you're not gonna get the gold
cause Simone withdrew.
She was saying, I owe it to my team.
I'm so worried about my performance.
We might not medal if I show up the way that I am.
So in some ways, the ultimate sacrifice.
Yeah, yeah, that's an interesting lens.
I only just saw that had happened today
and I didn't like delve deeper into better understanding it.
But that idea of expectations and making sense
of racial identity is obviously terrain
that you've explored in your writing.
You wrote a memoir called "Real American."
And in that book, you know, what I intuit
or extrapolate from that is this journey
towards self-love and self-acceptance,
which was this missing piece
driven by not really feeling like you fit in
to any of the respective communities being biracial
and with the parents, with whom you were raised
and the experiences that you had.
And it broke my heart to hear you share stories
about being at Stanford and trying to seek out community
and not really feeling like you could find it
in the way that you wanted
and understanding only later
that you had to heal like your own sense of self,
that it wasn't as much about you
or about the community welcoming or not welcoming you.
It was more about like how you perceived yourself.
That's exactly right.
Black biracial kid, white mother, black father.
My father, Rich, was raised in the Jim Crow South.
He would have been 103 if he was still alive.
So really different era, born in 1918,
escaped through track.
Was a great runner, they called him the Oklahoma Flyer
when he got to Bates was running track.
And his trajectory was do not be impeded by white racism.
He helped to eradicate smallpox in West Africa
in the 60s and being among Africans,
his blackness was not an impediment to his thriving.
And he really came of age as a black man in his 40s
in West Africa on the smallpox team,
came back to America in 1969 and was met with a,
what he was familiar with.
I was born to people who transgressed law
by daring to marry.
I was born to people who broke the rules
by falling in love, marrying and having me.
And I got the message from age four,
as a farthest back, I can trace it.
I knew as a four-year-old
that in the eyes of some white strangers,
my daddy was problematic
and that something was wrong with me too.
I gleaned that.
And I think my having lived outside the lines,
having been unconsummated positively,
certainly in the late sixties when biraciality,
multiraciality was not accepted the way it is now.
I've lived outside the lines my whole life.
And I think when I think about why do I,
why do I try to help people on their journey?
I was otherized from the start,
I was rejected, dismissed,
and I think that gives me a deep care
and concern for anyone who, for whatever reason
has been marginalized.
And your dad became Assistant Surgeon General
under Carter.
So we lived in Reston, Virginia, north Virginia,
when you wouldn't say-
Yeah, I noticed that.
But it was before high school, right?
It was because Reagan beat Carter, right,
as we were starting high school.
Right, and your mom being white,
but she would dress herself in beautiful African landings
and fabrics and things like that.
And that had its own-
'Cause she had spent seven years there.
Right, and, you know,
her always wanting you to be, you know,
proud of your blackness and your dad being someone who,
coming from that experience and having to weather,
you know, what he went through,
I'm sure compensating by wanting you
to be achievement-oriented so that, you know,
the color of your skin would be irrelevant
and you would be able to make your way in the world.
But the piece that was missing was you coming to terms
with that and what it meant to you.
Is that fair.
Thank you for reading so closely.
It's really quite moving when somebody holds your words
that close, it really is, thank you.
Yeah, that's exactly it.
They would, if my father was alive today he would say this.
My mother is alive, very much part of my life,
my amazing mother.
She would say if she was sitting here with me right now,
which she would love to be, by the way,
she would say, you know, we just knew
we wanted you to be comfortable everywhere.
We wanted to raise you so you could walk into any room
and get what you needed, command attention,
get the respect you deserved.
And I appreciate that that was their reality
and their truth.
What they overlooked is how desperately important it is
for a black or brown child,
and I can't speak for people with other identities,
but I'm sure it may apply to others
to have peers who look like them,
to have a few teachers who look like them,
to have neighbors who look like them,
to have a pediatrician or a librarian
or another adult authority figure who looks like them.
We say representation matters today
and I have lived a life that bears out that truth, Rich.
When somebody wrote, look,
I was at an all-white high school.
By all-white, I mean 1200 kids,
two Jews who were not considered white and me.
And on my 17th birthday,
somebody wrote the N-word on my locker.
And I was president of the student council,
doing very well academically, pompom girl,
singer in the choir, popular, if you will.
I was so ashamed to be the person
who had had the N-word
written on her birthday sign on her locker
that I didn't tell a soul.
But I'm here to tell you that if one teacher
over the course of those four years,
and they were all white,
so I don't need to say white teacher,
had pulled me aside and said, hey, kid,
you look a lot different from everyone else here.
I want you to know I'm here for you.
Should anything ever go down, you come see me.
If one teacher had thought
to have had that conversation with me,
I feel like my experience would have been so much better.
I would have felt less ashamed, less bewildered
and less alone.
I'd like to think that that would be the case today.
I do too.
A lot has changed for sure.
And yet look at us tumbling backward.
Yeah, it's a confusing time-
It is.
With all of this.
And as much as I feel like we've made progress,
there are so many glaring blind spots in all of this.
Yeah, agreed.
How does it look at Stanford these days on that tip.
With regard to race relations?
Yeah.
You know, so I did leave nine years ago.
I can't speak for the ins and outs of campus life today,
but of course know plenty of people who are there,
and I'm proud of our alma mater.
You know, Stanford was co-ed from the start.
Back in 1891 when the Ivys were only accepting men,
our alma mater excepted people of all genders,
as we would put it today.
Stanford is very much a place where diversity is cherished
and championed.
I think kids of color thrive there.
I think queer kids thrive there.
I think poor and working class kids
are increasingly thriving there
with concerted efforts within student affairs,
to ensure that folks in that community are supported
and mentored by folks who have walked that path.
There's, you know, a real intentionality
around supporting the individual on their journey.
And that place not to say it's perfect,
it is not perfect.
It is not an, you know, an institution
simply made up of its people and we are all imperfect,
but I think it's a place that can be proud
of what it's doing even as it seeks
to continue to be better.
Yeah, I hope so.
Yeah, well.
Well, how did you feel with the response
during the pandemic when they announced
that so many sports were going to be cut?
I watched the community feel anguish,
going back to this notion of Stanford always marrying
excellence in athletics with excellence in academics,
winning that NC2A Cup every single year,
making a decision to cut sports.
I mean, I just felt heartbroken for the athletes
because I know what it feels like
when you're so invested in your sport
and you're on kind of a ticking clock timetable,
like the lifespan of the athlete, you know,
particularly the ounce to a athlete is not very long.
So a year is like eons, you know.
That makes the difference between you
achieving your potential and missing your window
to do your thing.
And I just couldn't help, but think what I would have felt
like had I been in that situation and I would have been,
I would have been devastated.
Absolutely.
Yeah, I can't imagine having to figure that out
and just now watching the Olympics,
you know, you see Katie Ledecky got a silver the other day
in an event that, you know, I'm sure she,
and everybody expected that, that she would win,
and I couldn't help but think if the Olympics had gone on
as scheduled last year,
there's no way she would've lost that race.
And I don't know what her past year has been like.
It's been challenging for everybody,
and a silver's still amazing.
And she's an extraordinary human and athletes,
so good for her, but it's not without its toll.
And yet in the grand scheme of things like,
you know, we're dealing with a global pandemic
and people are dying, and you know,
we're trying to solve this problem and figure out
how to keep everybody safe.
These are not easy problems to solve
and compromises are made and decisions are made.
Some of which we'll look back on in retrospect
and say those were the wrong decisions,
and some of which of course will say,
it's good that we did that as soon as we did.
So, you know, I don't know beyond that.
I'm not sure I have any great insight,
but other than just compassion for all of this.
Back to this idea of raising healthy adults,
how to become a healthy adult.
What I loved about the first book,
"How to Raise an Adult,"
is that the New York Times called it
the black hawk down of helicopter parenting.
Like that is like the ultimate line.
That's so awesome (laughs)
Yeah, it was, look, it's pretty cool
when you get the call that your book's gonna be reviewed,
and then you read the review and it's positive,
and then they use an awesome line like that.
It was pretty much kind of a grand slam for me.
Right, and when I think of you in the work,
I think of Jonathan Haidt, Jessica Lahey, Susan David,
who tweeted this morning, you saw that tweet, right?
Yeah, yeah.
In response to us getting together.
Lisa D'Amour, Lori Gottlieb,
who comes up quite a bit in your writing,
as this sort of brain trust of people
who have thought deeply about the issue
of how to effectively raise young people
and position them for success in the world.
Yeah, I missed the question.
It's not really a question.
It's more just an observation.
Like, I suppose I would say you're not alone.
And having this perspective,
there are other people that share it,
who are excellent writers and deep thinkers
and academics, et cetera.
And so I feel like these ideas are percolating
in the culture at the moment.
And I wonder how much of it is being put into practice.
And I say this because when you share the experiences
that you've had with parents
when you were Dean of Freshmen at Stanford,
and I kind of see what I see out in the world.
There's this sense that we're producing a generation
of a very fragile human beings who are overly sensitive,
and it's all about safe spaces and entitlement,
and kind of the other catch words that you hear.
And I feel like for a while there was this sense that, well,
when they leave the protective enclave of the college
or the university, and go out into the real world,
they're gonna get a dose of, you know, real-life medicine.
And they're gonna figure out that, you know,
what worked for them in university
is no longer gonna work.
But instead, I think what we're seeing is,
you know, generations of people
who are matriculating into the grownup world
and then, you know, sort of rise into positions of influence
where they're hiring people.
And now we're seeing entire industries,
whether it's journalism or entertainment,
where that sensibility is now part and parcel
of kind of what we consume in terms of the news that we read
and the programming that we consume.
So how do you, yeah, that's not a question either, but-
Yeah, no, but I appreciate you're elucidating,
your perspective on this.
You know, there are a lot of folks who would call
the concept of safe spaces a snowflake concept.
And I think there are extremes one can go to,
or one is unwilling to hear a thought they don't like,
or that they find offensive.
And I find that very problematic
because I am very much a believer
that you counteract harmful speech with more speech,
that you have to know your enemy quote, unquote,
perspective in order to strengthen your own perspectives.
You have to be aware of quote, unquote, the other side.
So I'm not interested in safe spaces
where people put their fingers in their ears
and go la, la, la, and not listening.
At the same time, I think the requests for safe spaces
and the request for kinder language
has come out of the, let's not harass people doctrine
and has come out of the social justice doctrine.
Like let's treat people with dignity/
let's not be assholes here.
So I think I'm longing for that middle ground,
which is we can be frank and blunt, we can disagree.
And yet we're not demeaning people
on the basis of some aspect of their identity.
And I think Gen Z frankly, has the tenacity to get us there.
I try not to be too much of a blanket,
you know, Gen Z are this,
Millennials are that, Gen X is that,
but Gen Z has been raised,
first of all, the most diverse generation
in American history,
they've been raised with social and emotional learning
in their schooling.
Their media has depicted a more diverse range of characters
than any prior generation.
They've had active shooter drills
since they were kindergartners.
They have lived in a different America.
They have learned that the adults
have not solved the problems
and they seem collectively to have a voice
that says, move over, we're here.
Oh, and I forgot to mention,
they understand technology innately.
So I'm actually here as a Gen Xer 53 to say,
you know what?
I wanna stand with you, I'm not gonna be
that okay Boomer, elder, who tries to tell them what to do.
They are reshaping a world they arrived into broken.
The world was broken and they,
I think are people we can learn from.
So I'm here with curiosity
and a little bit of that older wisdom.
Like what don't forget, you have to try to talk to people,
look them in the eye, if you can, asterisk, I will say,
because what we now know more than ever
is some people have social anxiety
and some people are on the autism spectrum.
And you can't just say, look me in the eye,
what's wrong with you.
You have to appreciate not everyone can.
So I think we are in this 21st century
arriving at an understanding
of our many, many myriad differences
and the ways in which appreciating those differences
can actually evolve us forward as a human community.
Very well said.
I mean, certainly an appreciation for those differences
and a recognition and a respect for that
is crucial and important.
On the resiliency piece though,
I think perhaps what's getting missed,
maybe I'm totally off base here,
but is a resiliency to be able to engage with people
who have a different point of view
without it being necessarily, quote, unquote unsafe, right?
Can we have a nuanced conversation where two people
who disagree can sit down and maybe lead that conversation
still not agreeing, but do it in, you know,
in a way in which each is conducting themselves
with some level of like maturity and respect.
100%.
And I would say back to you, where did we go wrong?
Or maybe the more interesting question is
where do we turn to reinstate, if it ever did exist?
Where do we go to reinstate that manner of being?
Is it the family?
Is it youth groups that no longer exists
the way they used to,
because now it's all about performance-based youth groups
and it's not about character.
You know, where are we,
what institutions are currently failing us
and which ones are we gonna shore up?
You know, look at what's happening in America.
And it's like, my God, when did we stop teaching science?
When did we stop teaching ethics?
When did we stop teaching how a democracy works
and how it functions?
Like, why is it that all of these things we consider
the underpinnings of this experiment called America
seem to be fragile now.
And where do we go to shore them up
or completely rebuild the foundations?
I do think our universities have to be places
where people with wildly differing viewpoints,
can and will talk with one another.
Can and will find spaces to be heard.
I think that's essential, but-
It has to be that way.
It has to, but before university,
I think in our K-12 environment,
it shouldn't be about clamping ear muffs
and blinders on our kids so that they don't see
and don't hear but rather we get better
at engaging in difficult discourse.
And character is at the heart
of how we can bridge the gaps, right.
If you and I can be of good character,
be kind, treat each other with dignity
and have completely different viewpoints,
but not excoriate each other, not demean each other.
You know, we can get somewhere.
Right, right.
So we can point the finger at the family or the university
or the institution or the corporation,
but ultimately those are things
that we have very little control over.
What we do have control over
is how we acquit ourselves, right.
So in this book, your turn, you go through,
I mean, it's like fricking 500 pages long-
I'm sorry, I know, thank you for reading.
But what's great about it is-
'Cause life is long, Rich, or it should be-
I know.
You can't TLDR-
This thing is, I mean, it is a book, right?
It is a book.
And what's great about it is, it's perennial, right?
This is like a book that parents can give
to their young ones as they're emerging
into the grown-up world,
every single year upon graduation.
It's a book that I think every young person
who is grappling with how they're gonna navigate adulthood
can benefit from.
And me, being 54, wishing that I had a book like this
when we were back, you know,
finishing up our years at Stanford
to help me make sense of how I was gonna, you know,
try to figure out how to be a man in the world.
There was no book like this.
You know, I basically fumbled around
and made a million mistakes.
And until I finally started to figure
out a few things for myself,
but this is really kind of a roadmap and a manifesto
and a primer for things that young people
need to take responsibility for a need to think about.
But it really all begins with this inward journey
of self-connection, learning how to love yourself
and also learning how to pay attention to what moves you.
That's really, you know, the first base of this whole thing.
I love that.
You know, as you know, 'cause you've read it.
I opened by saying, I failed to write this book
that you're now reading
because I couldn't claim the authority
my publisher had given me
and given me a book contract to write it.
And then I appreciated.
Who is an authority on adulting?
Either we all are or one of us is, right.
It's not an authority in the traditional sense.
How dare you-
There isn't a PhD-
Hold yourself out as an authority?
Exactly.
There isn't a PhD in adulting I failed to obtain for myself.
I came to appreciate, I care about humans, I observe humans.
I've studied my own life pretty thoroughly.
Therefore I think being older,
farther into this landscape called adulting,
I can take what I know, turn around
and shine a warm light back on those younger than me.
That's all I'm trying to do.
The failings and the fumblings and the failings
and all the other stuff that you talk about
having gone through,
I call those life's beautiful efforts.
We need them.
They are our teachers.
You know, when you screwed up in the pool,
your coach told you you screwed up.
They told, maybe you watch tape,
I don't know what swimmers do, but like you,
you focus on bend your arm this way
or kick your legs that way, or take your breath this way.
You know, you screwed up and that allows you
to focus in on what you need to do differently and improve.
This is what life is.
It's a continual opportunity
to get better and better and better and clearer
on being who we are.
And so I'm hearing this book say, yeah,
you're gonna screw up.
Yeah, you're not perfect.
Forget that, that is not the destination you seek.
It is a fallacy.
You're here to learn and grow.
You know, I think we need a referendum
on what we're talking when we talk about failure.
I wish there was a different word that could replace that.
Yeah, 'cause nobody wants to fail.
Nobody does, but also no success is born
out of failing to fail.
Like all success comes from a resiliency around failure
and a tolerance level for messing up
because those are the experiences that teach us the most.
That's exactly right.
And let me model what can happen after you fail.
And you forget what you're about to say,
you can come back to it, which is I came to realize,
as I'm writing this book,
maybe I'm not attending to my mind and body
the way that I need to.
I'm advising my younger readers,
take good care of your mind and body.
I say are sort of like the wheels of a bicycle.
And you know, you're not gonna get where you wanna go
if you're not attending to them.
I'm now at a place relatively speaking
through mindfulness of much greater self-awareness,
which has led to self-love,
having exercised the demons of internalized oppression
that were in me saying you're not worthy as a black person.
I have dislodged them from my spirit and soul.
I've become clear on who I am and what I want
and where I wanna learn and grow now next.
And now my prayer, I'm not a religious person,
I'm a spiritual, but not religious person.
Now my ask is please let me live long enough
in this being that finally loves and knows herself.
And this is a sentence I could not have uttered at 21.
And I am delighted for the joy that fills me
when I say that.
I think I'm saying like, I am directly working my shit out.
I am in that process, and I have been through a lot
and there will be more.
And I know that the process is the work and is the life.
And I am loving it.
Please, now that I have come to this understanding
of what life is, let me have as much of it as possible.
Beautiful.
Oh, shit.
The poet in you just came out.
(Julie laughs)
I love that.
I mean, what is the process look like for you
to get to that place?
Like what specifically were the things that you were doing
to wrestle with the demons and exercise that?
You know, I have a little hesitancy
engaging with you on this because of who you are,
because you're an elite athlete,
because you are plant-based and vegan.
And I'm just saying like, let me just say, right,
I'm not that person.
You are that person, I know you're not judging me,
I'm pretty clear.
And yet just as if I was in the presence
of an Olympic athlete and I was an amateur in the sport,
I would be like, okay, can I really share my struggles
with this person?
Rich, I was afraid to go to doctors most of my life.
And that's because when you and I were juniors
at Stanford University,
I went into the Student Health Center
for a bronchial cough that had dogged me for five weeks.
And the doctor put me on a 1200 calorie diet.
He said, do you know how much weight you've gained
since you got to Stanford?
I was rowing for the women's crew team freshman year.
I shouldn't be a rower.
I'm not tall enough to row, but I loved it.
I stroked the third boat, Women's Novice Crew,
the best of the worst.
And felt the pride of wearing my uniform
and rowing for Stanford.
And I put on weight when I stopped rowing.
I'd put on about 30 pounds in two and a half years.
So I was a lot less than I am now, I assure you.
I was about 175 pounds that day,
which is far less than I am now.
And that doctor, instead of treating my cough,
said, do you know how much weight you've gained
since you got here?
And I didn't know.
And he came out with, went out and found a flyer
with a 1200 calorie diet.
And I learned, and I said, okay, what about my cough?
And he said, oh, we'll give you antibiotics for that.
And I learned in that day
that when I have a legitimate health issue,
it will be about my weight.
And it kept me from seeking a doctor's advice
when I couldn't conceive for two and a half years,
'cause I was worried I was too heavy to have a child.
I wasn't, okay.
I was afraid.
And in writing this book to try to help other people
on their journey, I said, go damn, Julie,
get into the doctor.
And I discovered that through a sleep study,
I wake up gasping for air at night
and I've been wearing a C-PAP machine now for two weeks.
And it has changed my life.
I'm thinking clearly now, I have this sense of what it means
to wake rested.
I'm looking after that self and it may sound weird
or simple to people, but I'm telling you my journey
to that mask, to that diagnosis, to that doctor's office
was a long one.
And I'm glad that I went and anyone listening,
who's like got a nagging anything,
wherever it might be in your mind or body.
And you're like, yeah, I probably need to get on in there.
Go, my voice is hear saying go, you know.
Information is largely good and you deserve it.
If you have the privilege of access to healthcare
and a way to pay for it, go and get it.
I'm sorry that you had that experience at Stanford
and that it took so long for you to come to terms with that.
That's heartbreaking, but I'm glad.
It sounds like, you know, that was a big solution for you.
So that's cool.
And I can't help but think that there's a relationship
between your writing and problem solving.
Like real American, really is the product of you
trying to make sense of this idea of racial identity
for yourself and in the process of writing these other,
you know, kind of parenting, adulting books,
you're able to kind of solve
some of these other lingering problems
that you've had, right.
Like they're living, breathing documents
that are compelling you to live the truth
that you're speaking on the pages.
Absolutely, I'm trying to achieve that.
I think I do experience that
and I'm trying to be of service.
I believe you can write all you want
about your life and your journal,
but if you're gonna take the leap and say,
other people should read it, I'm going to publish it.
It damn well better be because you wanna be of service.
And think you can.
And the joy that I've experienced
is the author of "Real American," which came out about,
close to four years ago now,
and the book signing line,
black and brown people will linger to the back.
Queer people will linger to the back.
People who've been marginalized and otherized
for other reasons will linger
and then they'll come, and you know what this is like
when people come to the book signing line,
and they lean in and they reach out for your hand
and they say, thank you for telling your story,
I feel seen, I feel less alone.
I've never said the things out loud,
you just delivered in your reading
or that are between the pages of this book.
And when that happens to me, I hold the person's hand
and we go back and forth and I smile
and I look at them in the eye and I say,
I wrote this for all of us.
And that's how I feel about the new book.
I'm just, I'm here rooting for everyone to make it.
And I feel like I don't have all the answers,
but maybe I can write a book that is like a mirror
that I hold up to you and you see yourself
where you need to in its pages.
Every reader is gonna relate differently, right.
Well, one of the reasons why this book is so long,
and I should qualify not,
I haven't gotten all the way through it.
I'm still in the middle of it.
But one of the reasons why it's like 500 pages
is because a lot of it is sharing the stories
of this just wide diversity
of young people's experiences, right.
Like you interviewed or conversed
with so many different types of people
from different walks of life
so that I can only presume, the reader will be able to find
the thing that they're looking for.
That's exactly right-
Or what they need to hear from the right person.
Like it's not just about the information,
it's who who's delivering the information
in a manner in which I can hear it
because I relate to that person's experience.
Yeah.
So back to what I said about never belonging,
being otherized from the start,
I know what that feels like.
I know what it feels like to open a non-fiction book
and feel like it was written for white middle-class
straight folk.
Right, that's like my book.
Well, But now you know, don't do that, right.
White folks had to think about those as a routine matter
because y'all are the, what we call the majority
and the norm.
And well, those things are thankfully
starting to be questioned and change.
And I'm trying to do my small part as an author to say,
I'm gonna write a nonfiction book
that purports to be for everybody
and to demonstrate that it is.
I'm gonna try to make sure that I'm careful
to mention and bring in, quote, unquote, everybody.
If I say you need to make eye contact,
I'm gonna say this may be hard for you
if culturally people like you
aren't supposed to make eye contact,
or you have social anxiety, you know,
or you are on the spectrum.
I try to, in the advice-giving, acknowledge the folks,
you know, to whom, for whom it might be different.
I'm also trying to say, don't dare give examples
that only emanate from one narrow swath
of the human community.
Everybody does matter.
Everybody should matter.
If everyone is to matter, we got to do a much better job
of bringing those who have traditionally been marginalized
onto the center of the page.
There's so many interesting and compelling ideas
in the book, and we obviously don't have time
to talk about all of them,
but there's a couple that I would like to highlight.
Not the least of which is this idea of fending, right.
So explain that meaning.
So what is fending?
Yeah.
You know, it's funny, Rich,
since the book came out,
people have really called out that term.
They're like, fending, do you use that term?
I was like, wait, what does that mean, exactly?
I know defending, fending for yourself.
So all I can say is this term
was such a part of my childhood.
My parents must have constantly been talking
about when you're growing up, you fend for yourself.
Because to me, it's a word that we use, like any other word.
Fending is this visceral animal kingdom truth
that applies to us humans.
We're mammals, can we posit that, right?
We we're mammals.
We have jackets and cell phones, right?
We wear fancy watches and sneakers and we are mammals.
And like any mammal parent,
we have to know for our own biological determination,
like we have to know our genes will get passed on.
How do our genes get passed on?
If our kids can fend for themselves out in the world
without us like any mammal parent.
We need to know that.
So fending comprises those small set of things,
small, basic, fundamental set of things
that humans gotta be able to do
in order to take care of business.
Take care of their body, their belongings, their bills.
Adulting is you know you are more or less responsible
for yourself.
It doesn't mean you go to loan,
but more or less your responsible.
So childhood someone else
was more or less responsible for you.
Some of your parents could show up
and did show up to look after you.
So fending is that I'm responsible for myself more or less.
It's the basics, which is why it's only, you know,
chapter two out of 13.
Right, and I feel like
parents understand this intellectually,
but in practice, end up kind of doing it ourselves for them
because it's just easier.
And we believe, or we delude ourselves into thinking
that by doing it while they're observing it,
that they're learning how to do it,
but actually you're handicapping them
and creating a dependency.
So there's actually a four-step method
for teaching any kid any skill.
And we'd seem to be ignoring steps two and three
and expecting them to go from step one to step four.
Step one is we do it for them.
Step two as we do it with them.
Step three is we flip the tables and watch them do it,
but we're still there.
Step four, as they can do it.
When we're over parenting we're in step one,
may be step two, where they're handling fixing.
Of course we can do it, Rich.
We've been fourth graders.
It's their turn, right.
Okay, we're -
But I'm late, you know, I got to get to work and you know,
this kid can't tie his shoes and I gotta get going-
Exactly, so if they gonna tie it,
then you have an eight year old who can't tie their shoes
or I'm too busy to teach them to cross the streets.
Then you have a 12-year-old who's never crossed the street
by themselves.
So you can see the ways in which we undermined.
We have to parent with a little bit more patience.
And for the longer term, I like to tell folks,
like it or not, and nobody likes it,
we'll be dead one day,
we have to raise our kids so that when we are gone,
and hopefully well before, they've got it.
They can look after us in our old age.
Obviously, there's a spectrum between helicopter parenting
and like kind of, you know, flagrant disregard.
So where's the line.
How do we find that sweet spot?
Or where is that line?
Like identifying that.
I suspect it's gonna be different with every kid, yes.
Sure, it's different for every kid.
Just as you've got your four
and you're gonna pay attention to their needs
and proclivities and whatnot,
and do things slightly differently.
Every kid is different and yet there are fundamental things.
So I'm gonna use the sport of bowling as a visual metaphor
for where you draw the line
or where you put up the bumpers.
Okay, when somebody is brand new at bowling,
you raise the bumpers so that their ball
doesn't go into the gutter.
So they have some chance of hitting up in
and not just flailing, not just, right.
When we over parent it's as if we're taking those bumpers.
And instead of just putting them at the edge
where the gutters are,
which the parenting equivalent of is,
make sure you kid doesn't drown,
make sure your kid doesn't walk into traffic.
Okay, life or death,
we're supposed to protect them from dying, okay.
And let them have the experiences of life.
Let that ball meander and maybe it'll hit a pen or two
and maybe over time, it'll hit three and then five
and then 10.
Van we bring the bumpers or the guardrails
or whatever they're called, clearly,
I'm not actually a bowler.
We bring them in so narrowly.
And if you could see me now,
I'm holding my hands at the width of a bowling ball,
so that the kid just throws the ball and we are right there,
making sure it goes straight down.
And they miss out on the experiences
that will teach them how to throw the ball straighter
and more confidently and with greater heft, okay.
That's that's the visual, okay.
We're also supposed to be delighted
by them learning a skill.
So overpay, parents say, when do you start?
Where's the line, is a question I get,
when do you start giving them independence?
I also get, and I say back, why did you stop?
When they were learning to walk,
you didn't over parent.
They fell, you didn't yell, get up.
We're embarrassed by you.
You know, your older brother walked in her, right?
We don't do that.
We take pictures and clap and laugh and video grandma.
If we over-parented in that moment,
it would be to get behind them on there and on our knees
and put our hands under their armpits
and slowly walk them forward toward the other parent.
And then we'd get to the end and say, we walked, right.
No, you didn't.
You did, the kid didn't.
If they forever fall into your strong body,
they haven't learned the skill.
So the right line there is remove the objects
on which they can impale themselves if they fall
while learning to walk.
Make sure the environment is safe.
But let them go and do it.
Yeah, yeah.
Over time, of course, this leads to,
the messaging is you're not capable of doing it yourself.
And that's why I'm helpings there, right.
And that, that really is pernicious.
And it messes with their developing brain
and their sense of self.
And it's hard to correlate a parenting style with anything
because parenting is 24/7,
and it's hard to have a control group of children
who weren't parented that way, right.
But people who study this have correlated
the over-involved parenting style
with higher rates of anxiety and depression in children,
because we are undermining the development of agency,
which is the sense I can,
and the development of resilience
that comes from, you know, things not going great.
And you discover, I can cope.
We undermine the development of these things,
which really are the foundations of a healthy life,
when we over-help.
There's an addiction piece in there too, right?
The more deprived of that agency at a young age,
the more there is there's a through line
with addiction later in life,
or when they get to college, et cetera.
Tell me, I'm not-
I know, I thought that was something
that was addressed in something that I read in your work,
or at least over consumption like this idea.
I mean, it's certainly, it's my story.
Like getting 3000 miles away, suddenly being in college
and on some level, you know,
free from the day-to-day kind of oversight,
that was a little bit overwhelming for me.
I went in the other direction
and kind of went a little bit nuts.
And I, you know, I have to believe
that that's a fairly common experience.
I imagine that's true, absolutely.
You know, what I read about is what I hear about
when I hear college administrators and high school leaders,
I'm talking about kids, interacting with kids,
the pre-gaming that can happen,
that does happen, of course, before parties,
and before events.
This is all pre-pandemic when getting together was easier.
Many people hypothesize that the pre-gaming today is in part
to help reduce the tremendous anxiety around,
I don't know how to talk to anybody.
I don't know how to be with them.
And I gotta get a little buzz on before I go to the party.
So I can, I mean-
So I can talk.
I did that.
Like, I completely relate to that.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's tough.
I mean, that's a good segue into the whole thing
about talking to strangers, right.
Yeah.
You know.
It's like, I just see this with young people
and with our youngest,
the discomfort with having a conversation
with a real human being
when everything is app-based and text-based,
it's like, I can't text the person.
No, you have to pick up the phone and actually call them.
And here's the question you need to ask, impossible.
Right, so we've-
Impossible.
We've got to train our kids how to use the phone,
isn't that weird?
But I'm here to say, I have done that,
I have said okay, learning to talk on the phone is a skill.
You've got to practice it.
It's like hilarious that we are even talking about this.
Rich, but here's why, but here's why, but here's why.
You grew up in DC?
Yeah.
All right.
When you wanted to call a friend in middle school
or high school, you called was a phone on the wall.
Maybe there's a long cord and you took it into your bedroom
if you're looking for privacy.
But no idea who would answer the phone for the party line.
Okay, so you would call and if you had manners,
which I'm sure you did, you would say,
hello, this is Rich or Rich Roll.
May I, hello, Mr. Smith, this is Rich.
May I please speak to whomever?
You had to, oftentimes you had
to get through your friend's parent or older sibling
before you could get to your friend.
Our kids don't have to do that.
They don't have, there aren't these places of interference
they can directly get to each other.
So of course it must be scary to think of, oh my gosh,
I've got to talk to somebody I don't know.
So yes, we have to teach it.
Yeah.
We have to teach it.
Just like we have to teach email etiquette,
how do you, if you're gonna thrive in the workplace,
you got to know how to write an email
that feels respectful to whomever might be
on the receiving end,
whether a customer or a higher up or a colleague, right.
We've got to teach these things.
But the big one here is stop pleasing others,
which goes to the people pleasing thing
that you and I share.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Every time you say that-
That's a tough one.
It does make me giggle, yeah.
Yes, no.
100%, I have very much been a people pleaser.
And frankly, once I became more self-loving,
then I got rid of a good chunk of it.
But it's still very much there, of course.
I'm just aware of it now.
And I'm aware of cropping up and I can feel it,
and be like, oh, that's what you're doing here,
people pleasing.
That chapter is stop pleasing others.
They have no idea who you are.
And that subtitle is the kicker for me because I am here,
remember rooting for them to thrive.
So I'm saying like, it doesn't matter what your parent,
your dad, your mom, your grandparents, your entire family,
your ethnic community, your peers think is legitimate.
This is your one wild and precious life.
They do not know you better than than you know yourself.
And if they say they do and you feel they might,
that is problematic.
You need a wrestle your life away from the people
in whose hands it is being held.
There's a bit of an ego piece in that as well because,
because it presupposes that, I mean,
your parents are going to care,
but most people don't care, right.
Like be you, most people would tell you that, right?
But we feel like we have to be a certain way
in order to get their approval
or to be perceived in the way
that we would like to be perceived
missing the bigger picture,
which is that people tend to gravitate
towards people who feel self-actualized.
Like it was an energy that that person admits
that makes them, you know, infinitely more attractive
than the person who is needy and just sort of coveting favor
in that weird way.
Absolutely.
I saw so many college students who were majoring in pre-med
'cause they had to, and maybe didn't wanna be pre-med
and were biding the time until they had the white coat
in the MD degree to tell their folks,
hey, I don't wanna be a doctor anymore.
But I also saw students who wanted to be nurses and MTs
and were consistently told, oh, you're too smart for that.
You know, go, go all the way and become a doctor,
as if there's this linear path
from one of those other professions to being a doctor.
And somehow it is a failure to stop
at the level of EMT or nurse.
I mean, who's more on the front line saving lives
in the moment constantly than an EMT?
And who among us has the right to say,
oh, that's beneath you.
A lot of people who wanna teach
and yet are at elite universities.
Are told, oh no, go for the PhD and be a professor.
Well, maybe you really wanna teach seventh graders
because seventh grade was when somebody saw you
in your capability, you didn't even believe in yourself,
but they did, and they mentored you
and now you're this thriving, successful person
because of your seventh grade teacher
and you wanna be that in a life
of a new generation of kids.
I'm here rooting for that to happen.
Yeah, I do feel like there's been some tectonic shifts
in education more broadly due to advances in technology
and also kind of what the pandemic has reaped
in terms of how we interface with education.
And also, I hope, I feel like there's a little bit
greater appreciation for trade than there used to be.
Like it used to be, look, if you've got a good job
as a trades person, you could support your family,
you could own a home.
And you know, that was respectful path.
And along the way, we lost our respect for that.
But now, because college has become so expensive
and inaccessible to so many people,
I'm seeing more and more people say,
do we really need college?
Like, is college really the right thing for this kid?
Maybe they can find, you know, their sense of self
in an other direction, and there's a permissiveness
to that that I think didn't exist
when we were graduating from high school.
I think that's absolutely right.
I think it's both because college has gotten more expensive
and out of reach and because more and more people
are willing to say, you know what,
I'm actually good at this thing.
I love working with my hands and this is what I make
and I'm good at it, and I wanna get better at it.
And the wages are good and the benefits are good.
You know, maybe there's even, you know,
that sort of old fashioned employer, employee handshake,
where it's like you work for me and I'll take care of you.
And that's pretty enticing thing these days.
Yeah, and I think the internet exposes young people
to a broader diversity of career paths than, you know,
the brochures that were on the coffee table at Stanford
when we were there.
And I think that allows people at a younger age
to have a greater depth of imagination
for what their life could look like.
And yet, I feel like education is still stuck
in a certain kind of system or rubric
that in many ways is outdated
given all the technological advances that we have.
And that we're gonna live to 100, right?
So many of your kids and mine as a routine matter,
live to 100.
So the notion that education is finite
or education is only for the young,
is just really outdated.
So yeah, I'm excited to see the ways,
well I'm optimistic and hopeful that the pandemic
has so jostled the way in which we try to educate folks
that the cleverest and most creative
and forward-thinking among us will seize this moment
to reimagine K-12 and higher ed
and the concept of education.
But of course we see many who are going right back
into the Rosen Sage on the stage and, you know,
content up at the front and it all has to, right.
I mean, there are plenty of people are just dying
to go right back to what it was, not learning the lessons.
To institutions that have absurd amounts of wealth,
you know, these funds and the amount of real estate
that, you know, Stanford sits on, for example.
You know, I feel like the university fundamentally
should be a public servant
and shouldn't be about restriction,
but should be about expansion.
And why, especially after going through 18 months
of the pandemic, couldn't an institution like Stanford
pivot to create a state-of-the-art digital experience
that would be widely available to a much greater number
of young people at a much more affordable rate.
They're not gonna be able to go live in Brandner,
but maybe from the comfort of their own home,
they could get some version of the Stanford experience.
That would be a great service to humanity.
If you took like all these collegiate institutions
and reformulated them so that they could create
greater accessibility, there has to be some deep thinking
around this at these institutions.
Or inside of them.
Or is their brand so rooted-
In the inclusivity.
In the exclusivity, like that's their bread and butter,
so I'm not gonna let go of that.
And certainly Malcolm Gladwell has just,
in the last couple of weeks written about that.
I mean, this is his thing which is going back.
I know.
Stanford is in his sights and he goes after it
all the time.
Yeah, yeah.
He's just written a beautiful piece on the absurdity
of the US news rankings, which I-
Well he's doing something I think
I think it's coming up in an upcoming episode
where he tries to game the system.
He goes to a smaller college and tries to figure out
what they need to do in order to get higher up
in the rankings to sort of play a game with it.
Right.
'Cause it's bullshit.
Yeah, is bullshit.
And that's a big thing of what you talk about,
which is getting parents comfortable with the idea
that it's not just bullshit
but there are all kinds of amazing institutions out there.
Just like let go of this idea that if your kid
doesn't get into the one of these colleges
that not only did he or she failed
that you failed as well.
Right, so it's not where you go, it's who you are
and what you're capable of when you show up wherever you go.
I am a huge fan of a small liberal arts college.
And I'll tell you why.
When I was an administrator,
a high-level administrator and Dean at Stanford,
I heard Stanford faculty saying,
wouldn't it be great if we were like Reed College,
which is a small liberal arts college in Portland, Oregon,
and what the context was,
and Stanford of course, is an amazing place
and excels at what it does and is,
but it is not a small liberal arts college.
And the faculty member was basically saying
the faculty a Reed only have to care
about mentoring and teaching undergraduates,
'cause there isn't, there aren't a set of graduate students.
There isn't a research imperative,
unlike a world-class university where the imperative
is to create new knowledge and disseminate it.
At a smaller liberal arts college
it's all about teaching and mentoring the undergrads.
And places like Stanford are trying their best
to incentivize faculty
to also care about the undergraduates.
And I think Stanford among its peers,
does a pretty darn good job of that.
But I'm here to say,
if you want a truly amazing undergraduate education,
be sure you're going to a place where the faculty
can make time to meet with you and to know you
and take an interest in your interests and your fears
and your dreams.
And that, that happens at small liberal arts colleges.
It also happens at community colleges.
And so those are two examples of categories
that folks should be really investigating
in addition to whatever other schools
are sort of commonly talked about in your community.
Yeah, yeah.
So if you're a young person listening right now,
and maybe you've got a job that you're gonna be starting
in the fall, or maybe you don't have a job
and you're really just not sure what the next step is,
what are the kinds of things that you say to that person
to help get them thinking about who they are,
what they might want to express
and kind of moving forward on a healthy trajectory?
I think the first thing I would say is start anywhere.
This comes from the field of improv.
This comes from Silicon Valley design thinking,
bias toward action start.
Any job is gonna give you some important pieces of data,
data about that industry and way of being in that industry
and data about yourself.
And your job is to try to be as learned
and effort-making as possible in that environment,
learn what you can about the place and yourself,
and then examine those data and say, well, how am I doing?
Do I like this, why?
How am I showing up here?
What does it tell me about myself?
What does it tell me I might wannna do differently?
Look, my first job was as a corn detasseler in Wisconsin
working for minimum wage, I know.
Corn detass, what?
Yeah, you have to take the tassels off the tops
of the corn stock so that something about cross pollination.
And that was my summer job after our freshman year
at Stanford.
And I lasted for two days,
'cause I was walking in the hot sun and miserable
and it was a minimum wage job.
So I quit and I got another minimum wage job
as a bus girl at Perkins, which was a 24-hour restaurant
where I got to interact with people.
And that was one of the earliest clues to me
that I'm a people person.
If the job can be really arduous or unpleasant,
but if there are people with whom I can interact,
I'll be fine.
That was an early clue to me.
So anyway, so to someone who doesn't know,
I'd say start anywhere and pay attention
to what you like and what you don't then iterate.
To people who are like, I could do this, I could do that,
I could do this, I got to keep all my options open,
I would say, keep your options open
is a blunt form of criticism or criticism in disguise,
usually from your parents are like,
oh, and when you say, I wanna do this this summer,
like, oh, keep your options open.
That's our way of saying, I don't like that option,
choose a different one.
Right, or if you fail, bad things are gonna happen.
It's sort of catastrophe, isn't it?
Yeah, so I would say your 20s
as at the design school at Stanford,
they call them your odyssey years.
Bill Burnett and Dave Evans have written about this
in their book and in the class they teach.
These are your odyssey years.
And that's, let that not be
an entirely privileged statement.
These are the years when you can explore,
what is my mind interested in?
What does my body like to do?
What are the environments in which I thrive?
What are the ways in which I like to learn and contribute?
You're gathering data about yourself.
Long gone are the days of you will do one thing.
You know, your grandfather, your great-grandfather
lived that life.
Your life is gonna have many more facets to it.
Yeah, no longer.
And it is a situation in which there's tension
between sticking it out in a job that's not great
to kind of develop a little bit of grit and resilience
around just weathering stuff
that just kinda sucks to do
versus, you know, I have a history of staying in jobs
too long because I thought, well, I'll just figure it out.
Like I just need to like, you know, suckle down
and suck it up until, you know,
I have a full-blown existential crisis.
But on the other hand, you know,
just quitting the moment it gets hard, isn't good either.
So there's a sweet spot in which you've got to develop
those kinds of whatever the skills are
that you're trying to learn in that job
while also having a healthy recognition of like,
this isn't gonna be my lifelong thing.
At some point, I'll pull the rip cord and try something new.
Right, so I would say don't quit in a day.
When something bad happens, don't just refuse
to come in the next day.
We do see that a lot more these days than in the past.
I would say go find your-
Probably a lot more.
A lot more people-
These days.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that's good, I don't know.
Well, I think if you're-
The Boomer in me is like-
You're not a Boomer, you're Gen X.
We need all the Gen Xes-
Yeah, but a Gen X, anybody who's not Gen X
is okay, Boomer.
I know, that's right, that's right.
I mean, I think here's the deal.
If your boss is tyrannical, you're never gonna fix that.
I would leave a situation with a truly tyrannical,
awful toxic boss.
The question is if they raise their voice at you,
are you considering that tyranny or toxicity?
You might need to develop a thicker skin.
And this is where talking to peers and talking to mentors
in the workplace or older workers,
who've been there longer, who know the environment
can give you a bit of a sense of reality check, you know.
Is this, how often am I likely to experience this?
How would you recommend I handle this?
You wanna try to stay at a job for two years.
You certainly don't wanna repeat, repeat, repeat, leaving
sooner than two years, more than a couple of times
in a row on your resume,
'cause it looks like you don't have staying power
or resilience or grit.
Yeah, yeah.
On the idea of keeping our options open.
The one thing I would say is, you know,
people ask me like, what would you tell yourself at 20?
Or what advice do you have for young people?
And I always say to invest in experience and live leanly,
like I think there's this, you know,
social pressure to accumulate like,
oh, I have to live in this kind of apartment
or lease this kind of car.
And, you know, my heart always breaks
when I see young people like over leveraged
because that does short circuit
the choices that they can make,
if they do wanna pull the rip cord
on a certain career path, because it's not working out.
That's good advice.
Like to have, you know, to always have
like a bit of a trap door
or just the flexibility financially,
to be able to segue into something else.
You know, I think the, I agree with all of that.
And the one piece of advice, I think the universe
tried to give me twice in my young 20s
was on the value of compound interest.
So I had a small windfall twice that I spent
and I can now look back and do the math
and see how much money I would have now
had I invested that money.
And so that's a message I try to make clear in the book.
The universe, just sort of parachuted in a little,
you know, cash and said, look,
if you wanna out, like, here's your little where you could-
Well, you know, they were things that at the time seemed,
at the time I felt I was making the right choice.
My father said to me, I'd rather give you this money.
He was spending $25,000 on my wedding,
which I realize is a privilege for many,
and, you know, nothing compared
to what many people spend today.
But he said, I'd rather give you this money
than spend it on a party that's gonna last for five hours.
And all I could say was, oh, daddy,
how could I not have a wedding?
But I'm able to see the value of that 25 grand
being 200 grand tonight.
We had a fire in our moving truck on the way to California
after I graduated law school.
And we had a settlement from beacons for about $25,000.
And we spent it on new furniture
and maybe even upgrading our furniture.
We're newlyweds, how could we not?
But I wish we had lived a little bit more like grad students
for a few more years and pocketed that cash.
Right, right.
But you're like, hey, I'm gonna go be
in this corporate law firm.
In Palo Alto.
I need a couch fitting my arise, yeah.
I know.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's tough to gauge those things
in the moment, isn't it?
Absolutely.
What are some of the things that in your experience
of talking to all of these young people
and the challenges that they have,
or the obstacles that they're facing,
what are some of the other kind of themes
that emerged from that, that are common,
but perhaps unique to this generation?
Well, interesting question.
I don't know the extent
to which they're unique to this generation.
I'll have to think on that.
What came to mind was we've been talking about work,
but discovering the identities one carries
is a huge task in young adulthood.
Hopefully it happens in young adulthood
as opposed to you don't figure it out until you're 40.
And oftentimes people are asking me when I do assemblies
for high school seniors, or talk to people slightly older,
they'll say, how do I talk to my parents about this?
You know, whether it's around work or identity.
And I have sort of five-step thing,
which is, steps one through four just prepare the way
for you to be successful at it.
Step one, is you say to your parents,
hey parents, can we find some time to talk later this week
or this weekend?
Smile on your face, respectful tone of voice.
You're signaling it's serious.
You're signaling I'm mature.
They're gonna be a little bit back on their heels,
that's fine.
You want them a little bit like, whoa, okay.
(extreme crosstalk)
Step two, you're in meeting
and you open with gratitude and praise
with whatever language works in your family,
whether it's love or respect.
You say, I know you love me and I love you,
which will further freak them out, right.
Or you say, thank you so much for raising me
with these values, and you've taught me, you know,
you've taught me so much, and I'm grateful.
You offer respect in whatever language
works in your family.
Now they'll be more freaked out.
Step three, you say, I'd like to talk with you about X.
I'd like to talk to about my plans for grad school.
I'd like to talk with you about my plans
for after high school, or I'd like to talk to you
about my relationship.
And I'd like to hear your plans for me.
And then I'd like to share mine, is that okay?
And they'll be like, yeah, okay.
It's like NVC, nonviolent communication.
Right, exactly.
And so step four, the parent talks,
I said, well, we've always known you're so smart.
We have always known you'd be this or that.
We just want, we want what's best for you,
But you know, we really think that (mumbles) whatever it is,
whatever barrier you're facing will likely come out
and you actively listen and reflect back what you've heard
so they feel heard and you say, did I get that right?
And you really don't be defensive.
Don't be mad, whatever they say.
Just try to listen dispassionately and interestedly,
and then finally, step five,
you can say, you know,
I'd like to share with you my thoughts now,
is that all right?
And steps one through four will have made it
so much more likely that their ears and hearts
and spirit will be open when you dare to say,
you know what?
The person I'm serious about is X.
And I realize you may not like, or appreciate
or understand or accept people like them,
but this is what's right for me.
And even if you can't understand or it wouldn't be
what you would have done,
it's what I need to do.
And I hope you will love me anyway.
You know, this is where it gets big and like, right.
How many parents and adult children
don't speak to each other anymore
because those conversations never happened
or really went awry because the parent insisted,
no, no, no, I know what's best for you.
And you shall not, whether it's about work
or about relationships.
Right, right, right.
It's almost like a coming out.
Yeah, it is.
It's similar to that.
It is, even if it's, I wanna be an AMT
instead of a doctor, you know,
or I wanna be a wilderness naturalist
and I realize we're a family of lawyers.
Or I wanna go to Wall Street,
even though y'all are theater geeks.
Like I'm agnostic, I don't have anything
against Wall Street.
If a kid wants to go to Wall Street
and they're from a family of artists,
they're struggling in the same way,
but they have more societal validation.
It's a rig that way, you know.
The artist's parents who raise their kids
in the artistic environment,
those kids end up rebelling by going full finance.
Like Alex speaking, family ties back in our day.
Yeah, and that's how our kids become our teachers.
I think in many ways.
My daughter is a dual major right now
in cultural anthropology and dance.
And there were years when I could not accept
or be proud of the fact that my baby girl is an artist.
And working with other people's kids,
denied the opportunity to pursue their dreams
woke me up to the reality that my child is an artist.
And I do not want her at 20 to be in a college environment
in tears trying to explain to an adviser
why her parents are making her be X, Y, and Z,
instead of letting her be who she is.
I appreciate that honesty, and vulnerability,
because as somebody who's this authority on parenting
and who has observed so much in the space
of how parents have improperly raised kids
or set them up for failure when they were endeavoring
to set them up for success, to acknowledge that,
you know, we all have our blind spots with this stuff.
You know, I think is important.
Yeah, I mean, I think when people hear me tell my stories,
they don't feel judged.
I hope they feel seen, and we can laugh and giggle
a little bit about why we over-parent,
and why our egos are to invest and we're too enmeshed.
But then I can tell a little bit more
of the outcome side of it
and what I've learned the hard way.
And I hope that it'll help other people
course correct a little sooner.
Yeah, I think I've gone on a journey with this as well,
to the extent that, you know,
you and I are both products of a certain type of education
and a way of orienting your life around that ladder, right.
Like you do this, you do this, you do this,
it worked for a while for me,
we each got out in our own respective ways,
and even though I'm aware of the pitfalls
or where, you know, where and how it kind of led me astray,
that's my imprinting.
So when I'm raising kids,
I'm like, well, this is the way it's gonna be.
And now my kids were like, well, not so fast, you know.
And I'm like, what do you mean, you know?
And then I have to grapple
with my attachment to that, right,
in the many ways that you talk about in your books.
Like, where am I projecting onto my kid
a certain expectation or an assumption
about the way that they should pursue
their young adulthood
and how much of that is in a meshed relationship
where in my ego is associated with certain outcomes
that have nothing to do with me.
Yeah, ego is certainly possibly piece of it for you,
for me, for anybody listening.
It's also just hardcore love and fear.
We know more about the world and how it works.
We want them to be successful, healthy,
safe, happy, and we think we know the path to those things.
So why would we not curate their environment?
And yet, and yet we say, I just want my kids to be happy.
I just want my kids to be happy.
So unpack that.
Right, and yet we do all these things
that lead to a straight jacket in childhood,
and you only can do X, Y, and Z,
and then they're not happy and they resent us.
Or maybe they are sort of wildly successful
in a career that we chose and resent us
because they didn't get to do what they wanted.
You know, we we've lost sight, Rich,
I think of what it means to be happy.
I mean, I think, you know, I think I know
we've gotten to those places,
but too many of us think happiness equals
the corporate degree with X salary.
When in fact happiness comes from being content
with what you have and with who you are, right.
Yeah, aligning your life in accordance
with your particular values and being engaged
with the world in a manner in which you're able to,
you know, harness the things that you care about
and share them with others.
So lemme be super practical.
A kid who grows up here in LA or where I live in the Bay,
high cost of living, may not be able to live as an adult
where they grew up if they choose a profession,
a career, a trade where they don't earn a lot.
But they can go be that person in a more affordable city.
I mean, I think we're gonna see a lot of Gen Zers
flocking to cities and towns that have jobs,
at a reasonable cost of living,
better around climate change, right.
There are places that are hospitable to young people.
There are those places.
Yeah, those places exist.
Those places exist and they need to exist.
Something is very wrong macro economically.
When not enough of those places exist,
and of course, we're seeing that in your town and mine,
but I'm here to say to young people listening,
there are places where you can be a social worker
or a third grade teacher
and afford a decent place to live
and have a great quality of life.
It just might not be in Palo Alto.
Right, but if you choose to stay in one of these places
on your checklist of the things we traditionally look at
as steps along the path towards adulthood,
it's like go to college, you know, move out,
get the job, get married, et cetera.
But on the move out piece, like leaving home,
that's less and less possible for a lot of young people.
We're seeing young people returning to the home
and staying there for periods
that extend beyond what we were used to
when we were younger because cost of living is so high.
And yet we have the opportunity to reframe that.
Not as some kind of failure,
but as an opportunity to continue
to develop your adult skills,
even though you're within the confines
of your parents' home.
Yah, like you have to live at home,
that doesn't excuse you from developing these other skills
about how to become an adult.
That's right, Rich.
So it's not with whom you live or where,
it's, how are you behaving wherever it is you live.
And so there are young adults who came home in the pandemic
and showed up as young adults.
They'd been accustomed to freedom,
college or the workplace,
they're back at home in their childhood bedroom,
but they sat down with their folks,
and they're like, hey, let me go get the groceries.
It's safer for me out there.
Can I make a meal X times per week
because I wanna contribute,
like mature, grownup participant.
There were others who came home
and retreated to their childhood bedroom
and some combination of their parents.
And they, you know, their behaviors (indistinct) I5 again.
So there's nothing inherently wrong with choosing
to live with your parents as an adult.
It's imperative, however, that everybody in that arrangement
be given the independence and freedom
and take on the responsibilities
inherent with that independence and freedom.
So that everybody's needs are met
and boundaries are respected.
Yeah, that's been our experiment over the last 18 months.
Our boys had moved out.
They were living on the other side of town
in an apartment with some friends.
When the pandemic hit, we were like, please come home.
We don't know what's going on over there.
And they ended up just moving back in,
and 'cause it was ridiculous for them to pay rent
in an apartment that was tiny,
that they, you know, we're gonna have to sit in
by themselves for all this period of time.
But it's been this exploration of, you know,
collective living with, you know, young adults
who aren't kids, but now they're back at home living
and we're not charging them rent,
but there's a certain set of expectations
that come with that.
They're gonna cook meals
a certain number of nights a week.
They're helping out with the carpooling
and the driving of the other kids.
And you know, we've been able to like find our way
with all of that and make it all work.
And it's actually been great.
I've loved having them back home.
Like I don't want them to move by now.
They're going to be again soon,
'cause they have dreams and goals
that they're chasing, et cetera.
But I've come to look at it as really precious
and something that would have not have happened
had this, you know, pandemic, not occurred.
Absolutely, I've had the same thing.
Mine are a little younger than your boys, I think, right.
And we worked on, I love that,
I think you just use the term repatterning or patterning.
I use that term with respect to mine,
particular my older one who I write about in the book
as having had some challenges around ADHD
and anxiety in his young adulthood.
And he allows me to talk about this.
So I'm not outside of bounds here.
We've been working as a couple, my partner, Dan and I,
on repatterning our way of being with this kid.
We realize we've been too worried
about some of his sensitivities and things
such that we've over-managed and handled over-helped,
which conveys, I don't think you can,
which a psychologist at Yale has written about
in "The Atlantic" so beautifully.
When we try to curate the environment
to meet their every need,
we can turn their fears and to full-blown anxiety.
It's as if we're saying that thing you fear
is such a big deal.
I agree, I will make sure it never happens.
And it undermines their ability to develop
an ability to cope and and the resilience
that comes as you cope.
And so we're repatterning with that kid
and in family therapy, which is so wonderful
and learning how to stand shoulder to shoulder
with this man, I have a 22-year-old son,
in a way I don't mean shoulder to shoulder right next to,
I mean, near him walking the journey of life
in his vicinity, rather than pushing him from behind
holding him by the hand or dragging him from the front.
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, it is great.
One of the things that I plead guilty to doing (chuckles)
is sitting down my kids at various stages
over the course of their young lives and saying, listen,
you have everything you need to be successful.
You literally could be anything that you wanna be
if you set your mind to it.
And I felt so proud of myself for that big speech.
So what did I do wrong here?
Well, I think the only missing component is,
I mean, you added, if you put your mind to it,
a lot of parents just say you can be anything
you wanna be.
If you put your mind to it, A,
if you work damn hard is B, and that was missing, I think.
And I think, C, I would add things
may often not go your way,
but with hard work and continued effort,
you'll be surprised at how much you can accomplish.
So I think what we're trying to do is embed in the message
that it's tremendous hard work that is required
to be anything you wanna be.
Yeah, I always try to hammer home that piece of it.
I figured.
'Cause that's kind of like my jam.
But, but I also, you know,
a big piece for me also is just modeling the behavior.
Like I'm not big on telling them what to do or not to do,
but I'm all about just making sure that I'm modeling
the kind of habits and behaviors that I wanna see in them.
Not that there's an expectation
that they're gonna follow in that regard,
but just so there's a bit of a north star there.
Like they know, you know, like this is how I conduct myself
in the world.
Absolutely.
So how has that, like, how does that measure up
in terms of, like how impactful is the modeling of behavior
versus like what's coming out of your mouth
and the things that you're saying to your kids.
I think anybody who studies or writes on this subject
would say they watch what you do
and pay far more attention to that
than they listen to what you say, right.
So obviously, we have to walk the walk.
We absolutely have to walk the walk.
And my kids called me on it.
When I talk the talk about any college is fine.
Oh, any college is fine, any college is fine,
I was actively counteracting the Palo Alto message
of you have to go to one of these four colleges.
It's gotta be crazy in Palo Alto.
It is crazy.
Well, it's gotta be crazy here-
All could change with all those Silicon valley people,
like, I can't imagine the links
to which some of those parents are going to get in the-
Of course, well, in the college admission scandal,
the varsity blues was an indicator.
But when I, you know, I was with my daughter,
I was not happy with her false schedule senior year.
And I let her know and she's like,
mom, there literally is nothing else I wanna take.
They screwed up my schedule,
I'm gonna fill it with a study hall.
And I was like, find another class to take,
find another class to take.
That college you've said you wanna go to,
we'll want you to have had another class to take.
She said, are you telling me to just take any class
to please some college?
I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure
that's not what you've said.
I just looked at her sort of like, oh, shit.
Even I who tells other people what to do
I'm still getting it wrong.
And she called me on it and I owned up to it
and told her, thank you.
And I apologize and stepped back.
I had to step off.
I was like, I was on the platform with her
forming the way in which she would dive.
Yeah, and let me be clear when I say modeling behavior,
like that's probably 10% of how I actually behave.
Like I'm an idiot most of the time.
And I do all kinds of crazy stuff
that my kids are like,
I can't believe you did this or that, so.
You know, talking about, first of all, that's fine.
That's okay, and it's wonderful for people
to know that you're a normal person.
You talked about the chapter, don't talk to strangers.
And we talked about how important it is to teach kids how.
My husband and I, Dan, my partner, husband,
we were in the kitchen one day recently,
Sawyer, our 20, now 22-year-old was in the kitchen
making food.
We were at the other end.
We were talking about the fact that we had purchased
this expensive thing from a man
and we were not happy with how it had all gone down.
And so we were engaging around how do we talk to this guy?
What do we say that is respectful of him,
but also communicates our needs.
And we were brainstorming how to write an email to this guy.
Sawyer quips, thank you for having this conversation
in front of me.
We looked at him like, what are you talking about?
He said, it's helpful to me to hear that adults
have anxiety about how to talk to other adults
and to hear you talk through your options
about how to do it.
And we realized we'd been having all of those tough regular,
but sort of how to live life,
how to negotiate the complicated terrain
of human interaction or a bureaucracy.
We had negotiated all of that
out of the earshot of our kids.
'Cause some wise person said,
don't let your kids hear you struggle or be an,
ah-ah, that's how they learn.
So we said, you're welcome,
and we'll try to do it more often.
Yeah, I'm a big believer in that as well.
The flip side of that, of course,
is that your kids learn early and often
that like parents don't like (indistinct) know anything,
and nobody knows what they're doing,
which is kind of like their bursts.
It's bursting this, you know, bubble
that like, oh, when I grow up, like I'm gonna get it.
I think what you don't wanna do is blubber
all of your difficult.
You don't wanna be hyper-vulnerable with your kids.
They need to see you are an authority,
they are safe, you are confident.
So they can't, they don't want to see you fall apart.
But, again, it's about balance.
It's like, let them see-
They need to know that like you've got their back
and they're safe and all of that.
But the idea that your life is not without, you know,
struggling with how to manage certain aspects of life,
I think is important.
That's Telegraph to them.
And the other thing is money.
You know, money's a big thing too.
I mean, I grew up never once, you know,
did anything, you know, helpful,
was anything helpful, shared about like,
how to deal with money,
which is just a verboten subject off the table completely.
So I had no sense of that whatsoever.
You know, simple things like balancing your checkbook,
but just like that whole world that suddenly
when you're a young adult and you're in the world,
becomes absolutely crucial to your survival.
And was just a complete black hole
in my learning experience.
Same here, and then I was perhaps like you,
one of many who find themselves embarrassed and bewildered,
I'm so educated, and yet they don't seem to understand
how money works.
In my money chapter I talk about how critical it is
that as a young person,
you care about your 65-year-old self
who will have wanted you to pay attention to its needs,
to their needs at the same time
to not be an indentured servant to your 65-year-old self,
'cause who you are now matters too.
It's about a balance of the now and the future.
And in that chapter, I profile somebody
who came out of the working poor into community college,
into a job with UPS as a driver,
and is now finished 35 years
and has such a beautiful career trajectory,
is now solidly middle class with a second home,
Gainesville, Florida, and a stock.
And, you know, has the American dream.
And how he did it, and I have someone else profiled
who's an artist from Stanford, majored in dance,
took out student loans for Stanford
and for University of Florida MFA
to be a dancer in New York City.
So she's got all of the student loan debt,
and finally realizes I've got to pay this.
I'm only earning this tiny amount as a dancer,
I gotta get rid of my debt.
And she became this disciplined person
who would walk around three blocks out of her way
to make sure the food smells from her favorite restaurant,
we're offering in the air so that she wasn't tempted
to spend money at a restaurant instead of her budgeted food
from a grocery store.
And she paid down her student loan debt
with 50 grand with interest, 32 principal.
She paid it down at three years on an artist's salary.
And how she did it, and the fact that she's now
a financial planner with a side gig, when she's not dancing,
she can advise people on their finances,
you know, that's who she is.
And she advises people.
She went out on Facebook and said,
I'm gonna be debt-free in three years,
I'm debt-free today.
And she didn't get any comments.
She got a ton of likes,
but she got all these direct messages
and she realized people are ashamed to comment
I need your help.
in the direct messages it was how did you do it?
How do I start?
Can you help me?
Nobody would say it in public.
And so this is now, it's funny.
She's like a finance person, that's her side hustle
where the art is the main gig.
For many people it would be the reverse.
Right.
Yeah.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, I think it's a huge problem,
especially amongst young people
who are emerging from college or in situations
where they're able to get those loans, which, you know,
feels like in certain instances are handed out
without kind of a manual for like what this actually means
and what to do with it and all of that-
And credit cards.
And we're just basically sending young people
out into the world saddled with unbelievable debt
that shortcuts, you know, the choices
that they're capable of making.
And, you know, it's just wrong.
There's gotta be a better way to do this.
Absolutely, it is wrong.
This generation has more student loan debt
than any of us ever had.
It's terrible, and you can't get rid of it.
You could declare bankruptcy, it's never goes away.
It's ridiculous.
And the cost of living is too high in many cities
such that you can't afford a one bedroom, right.
What are they supposed to do?
And their granddad's saying, what's wrong with you?
I got a job in my day.
It's like shut up, its not you day.
Exactly, right, when you could go work at the factory
and own a home and a car and all that like that,
you just can't do that anymore.
That's right, maybe one day, maybe soon.
Yeah. Well, we got to wrap this up, but final words,
maybe like a final word for the parent
and a final word for the young person,
somebody who's new to these ideas,
who's got a young person in their house
and maybe they've made a few mistakes,
they're trying to get it right.
Like where does this person begin,
other than with picking up your books, of course.
Yeah.
To any parent listening,
I hope it's clear I'm with you, I'm in it.
I'm screwing up left and right.
I'm just really mindful of what I'm doing
and trying to iterate and get better.
So I'm here to believe in you.
If you're hearing yourself in any of the examples
we've been discussing, that's step one.
Now go to step two and ask yourself
what am I gonna do about it?
And be in community with other parents
who are tired of the rat race
and are tired of micromanaging your kid's existence
in order to get them to the right future,
the right future as a kid who leaves your home
with agency and resilience and good character,
those are three things you can instill for free.
And you don't have to play this crazy game of lunatics,
making everybody crazy.
That's exactly right.
And to young people listening,
I would say, keep listening to great podcasts
because there's so much to learn
from the experience of others who've gone before you
or going through it with you.
And this is your one wild and precious life.
It is nobody's business to tell you how to live it.
I want you to figure out who you are,
by which I mean, what are you good at?
And what do you love and where do you feel
a deep sense of belonging?
Find the Venn diagram, intersection of those things,
go out and make that life happen.
It's waiting for you.
I think you just stuck the landing
like a Simone Biles floor routine.
Powerful, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's beautiful, that was super fun.
Is it done?
How do you feel, we're still recording,
but like, you good?
I'm good.
Did we hit everything?
I think so.
Yeah, it was fantastic, thank you so much.
In the meantime, everybody pick up your turn,
"How To Be an Adult," is quite the book.
Like I said, I think this will be a perennial bestseller
for parents and young people alike,
something that you'll wanna gift your young person
upon graduation and a book for every young person
who's entering the work world or the world of grownups
and trying to make sense of this insane spinning planet
that we're all sharing.
In the meantime, if you wanna connect with Julie,
what's the best place to send them to?
Your website, your Twitter, your Instagram?
Absolutely, I'm everywhere on social
@jlythcotthaims, that's my first initial,
last name, no hyphen.
Maybe even TikTok one day soon, we shall see,
but definitely Twitter, Instagram,
Clubhouse and Facebook.
You have points for me?
Oh, you're doing the Clubhouse thing, aren't you?
I'm trying.
I mean, Adam Grant is somebody who I know, we both know,
and I'm trying to, he helped me out with it a little bit.
My website is julielythcotthaims.com
without the hyphen.
And that's a great way to learn more about me.
So yeah, follow me, check me out.
If anything I've said resonates,
I do like to interact with folks who wanna interact with me.
Cool, and let's do this again sometime.
I would love that.
All right.
Thank you.
Thanks Julie.
Peace, love.
Namaste.
(Rich laughs)
(dramatic music)